[Música]
y llegó el momento de revista de prensa
en directo américa de france 24 y hasta
conmigo lista en el estudio de rosa
pérez más de euros a bienvenida feliz
mañana abrimos esta sección de revistas
de prensa con un tema chileno rosa y es
que a un mes de que sea electo el
presidente de chile gabriel boric tome
posición mejor dicho que a un mes de que
tome la posición el medio español el
salto analiza las claves de su gobierno
rosa buenos días exactamente el
periodista jaime borde el gil hace un
análisis de los mensajes que mandó
gabriel boric cuando presentó a su
gobierno y bien señala que por un lado
mandó una un mensaje muy claro a las
mujeres al elegir 14 ministras frente a
10 ministros y también a los jóvenes y
aquí hay siete miembros de este gabinete
que tienen menos de 40 años pero aquí no
acaban los mensajes dice que también
mandó pues una mano tendida a la unidad
de la coalición que lo llevó al gobierno
a ser electo presidente de chile la
coalición apruebo dignidad y que por
ello eligió a camila vallejo del partido
comunista portavoz del gobierno porque
recordemos que esta coalición apruebo la
dignidad es una coalición entre el
frente amplio y el partido comunista y
por otro lado que también quiso mandar
un mensaje de la necesidad que tiene de
ampliar la base ya que no cuenta con
mayoría en ninguna de las cámaras y que
la máxima expresión ante esta voluntad
es pues el hecho de elegir al ex
gobernador del banco central mario
marcel como ministro de hacienda vamos a
ver como acabar resolviendo todos estos
complicados equilibrios pasamos la
página rosa cambiamos de tema
continuamos en afganistán porque hoy
justamente se cumplen exactamente seis
meses desde que los talibanes tomaron
kabul y el periódico francés mediapart
destaca a través de afganistán una
angustia que será de nosotros
de hecho dos periodistas de mediapart
recital sus inmortales saben woody hacen
un recorrido por el país para ver cómo
está la población que describen que vive
ahogada bajo la represión el hambre y la
desesperación y hemos querido
seleccionar un par de personas que dan
su voz en este texto entre ellas
abderrahim que es un pequeño agricultor
de los montes baba que dice que teme más
que la crueldad talibán de las
lapidaciones o los cortes de manos del
pasado teme el fin del conocimiento dice
occidente ha evacuado todos los que han
hecho progresar el país estos últimos
años nuestros ingenieros nuestros
intelectuales nuestros profesores
nuestros periodistas sólo quedamos
nosotros los agricultores y estos
salvajes por el contrario en el aire
puerto de candás se encuentran con nadie
más que se define como una influencer de
los derechos humanos y que regresa desde
canadá porque dice y defiende la
necesidad de cambiar el país desde
dentro y regresamos a nuestra región con
un reportaje del diario punto es rosa
titula casa frío un refugio lgtb y para
volver al mundo atrás y violencia esto
en mexico exactamente este refugio abrió
durante la pandemia hace de hecho 18
meses porque tal y como señalan a los
organizadores las personas que lo
abrieron durante la pandemia se acentuó
la violencia intrafamiliar contra las
personas lgtbi y entre distintas voces
que aparecen en este texto destacan las
de leo adolfo y miguel ángel los tres
vivían a situaciones límite situaciones
de calle tras ser expulsados de sus
casas de sus hogares y decían a que esto
fue la última esperanza que tuvieron y
es que en este centro se encuentra
acompañamiento pues es psicológico en
búsqueda de empleo o acompañamiento en
términos de salud
los organizadores defienden sobre todo
en la necesidad de huir del paternalismo
pero de ofrecer espacios seguros sobre
todo ahora que este mes de enero se ha
registrado como uno de los más violentos
en términos de crímenes de odio contra
las personas lgtb quienes rápidamente
rosa finalizamos con una investigación
de la revista 'time' dentro del taller
clandestino de facebook en áfrica
efectivamente hablamos de la empresa
sanma que es una de las empresas que
facebook externaliza alrededor del mundo
para que ejecute lo que se llama
modelación de contenidos la modelación
de contenidos recordemos es el hecho de
supervisar revisar lo que se publica en
facebook por si hay contenido ilegal o
digamos inapropiado como violaciones
torturas asesinatos y sacarlo de la
plataforma antes que llegue al público
general y ha habido trabajadores
alrededor del mundo que han señalado los
daños psicológicos que implica realizar
este tipo de trabajo pero
particularmente esta empresa sanma que
está basada en nairobi en kenia y se
encarga de la moderación de contenidos
de toda áfrica sub-sahariana además los
trabajadores defienden la bueno señalan
la imposibilidad de sindicarse de hecho
destacan una cultura laboral marcada por
el trauma mental la intimidación la
imposibilidad de sindicalizarse y de
hecho consideran su trabajo como una
forma de esclavitud moderna y de
neocolonialismo sólo para terminar raúl
aquí en la foto vemos a daniel motown
un trabajador de esta empresa que fue
despedido en 2019 tras intentar montar
un sindicato pocos días después de que
altos cargos de facebook llegaran a
nairobi para supervisar como estaba
funcionando esta empresa externalizada